la belle-dame de pque à la froide
esthétique au sourire
ironique de son
épine me
pique et c'est l'histoire de Richard
Paul Frédéric et Fabien chef de bord et
conducteur de train des collègues qui
ont deux passions communes à la musique
et des valeurs avec deux autres amis
Thomas et Yannick ils conçoivent un
premier album l'an dernier aujourd'hui
c'est une autre rencontre qu'il est
réuni en studio euh grass qu'est-ce que
tu penses du refrain avec les de voix tu
crois que c'est c'est bien c'est né ah
moi
je j'ai affire à des professionnels
je l'actrice grâce de capitanie est
aussi poétesse les deux univers se
rencontrent et l'aventure démar dans le
deuxè recueil de poésie il y a un
chapitre où il y a marqué si on chantait
et euh bah il a pioché un peu là-dedans
il m'a mis un premier en musique puis là
le deuxè mesdames et moi vraiment il a
une
équipe je m'incline on se rend compte
que ben on on parle des mêmes choses on
parle des mêmes valeurs et puis bah du
coup voilà on part sur une collaboration
et puis voilà maintenant on est proche
on s'entend bien et puis on on a
l'intention de de de continuer à essayer
de de mettre de la musique sur ces
textes parce que moi cé c'est très très
riche en texte en poésie et c'est les
valeurs que quelque part on aimerait
aussi mettre en avant avec beaucoup
d'humilité et de bienveillance un EP de
6 titres est en fabrication pour une
sortie prévue début 2024 les deux
premiers morceaux sont accessibles déjà
sur les réseaux sociaux avec une telle
égérie et ambassadrice le groupe
miberichon missolono devrait connaître
un regain de
notoriété